let's bring bill in
right now um guys listen
i don't there's really nothing i need to
say about this [ __ ] dude
i'm one of the funniest dudes going
without a doubt um
and uh we got a chance to spend a couple
days
uh hanging out a couple years back in
boston at the roast of uh
david ortiz it was a ton of fun
everybody please help me welcome bill
burr bill what's going on man
how are you sir it finally happened
you good dude i can't hear you of course
you can't hear me why would why would
any of my [ __ ] ever
there we go here we go there you go how
are you it said i didn't have the latest
version of my
my stupid phone thing so i don't know if
this is gonna work
it works fine man how you doing
i'm good are you picking up a southern
drawl out there already
nah i'm just when i smoke weed i hold on
to my vowels for a long time
oh all right let's say you don't you
don't sound like you
no i i i have lost a little bit uh
for whatever reason i'm losing my voice
a little bit so i'm super scratchy today
um but uh i feel good dude
let me ask you something first of all
how are you how's your family
uh everybody's great everybody's great
yeah having a good time being uh
you know uh dad just being around the
house it's been great i love it
how old is your kid
i get a four and a seven month can i ask
you a question man
i i i'm so happy man
and i was wondering what kind of doritos
i'm eating a slice of pizza dude i'm
like get in it man diapers and [ __ ] you
know
dude i remember i remember people ask me
why i eat so fast
i eat fast because i had to feed kids
which means i had to eat standing up
do you know what i mean like that is i
learned
half your meal is finishing what they
didn't eat and that's how you get the
dad bod
exactly right now i but i do you know i
i like asking people this
because i i for me uh i remember
somebody asked me when i was a when my
kids were younger
and i was like wow what
what would you say you hope your kids
get from you and what would you say you
hope they don't get from you
besides don't say something like your
face or whatever the [ __ ]
but do you know what i mean oh i didn't
know you're going to dictate my answers
on this
jesus
you were all hippy dippy in l.a you
smoke a little weed in nashville
obviously
um
what i hope that they get from me um
i guess and i didn't have this when i
was their age drive
to go in and believe to go and
think that you can do what you want
for a job i guess uh what wouldn't i
want them to get from me
um only one thing that's a
long list my
my my temper yeah
you know what's interesting is that for
me
what i hoped they got for me was also
what i hoped they didn't get from me
do you like i hope my kids i am
what's that your metabolism yeah i hope
they get
kept you in shape but you could only get
so big and i know you probably came up
in the 80s and 90s and you felt your
biceps were less than
some other people but now now you just
look like this shredded
let me tell you something bill when i
was in high school in the 80s in western
mass
and you know we used to go we had an old
mall and a new mall i don't even
remember what their real names were i
just we called them the new mall
and the old mall right right and um
man they at the old mall they used to
always tease me about how skinny my arms
were
oh [ __ ] they were like don't come
back to the old mall
but they they
you got new ball arms
listen i used to i remember my brother
used to work at chess king do you
remember chess king
that store at the mall dude anybody who
shot the chess king fingered their first
check within those two weekends second
you got those skinny ties little dance
shoes
and you put the moose in your hair you
were [ __ ] in there
my brother had that bar you know
chest king i haven't heard about that
forever yeah well my brother used to
work there so i used to get 15
off so you know i was going into chess
game
and uh but they um i remember i was like
because jessica was at the new mall it
wasn't at the old mall
you know the old mall had like papa
jinos and uh
did you guys have papadum king was for
that white kid who had a little flavor
yeah he was i don't know if you know but
he had an urban
feel i i lived in a cul-de-sac but
loved it couldn't get enough of it bill
i was in a breakdancing group in high
school
we were the jam jam hurst breakers
oh yeah oh yeah there you go yeah the
jam horse breakers we used to go up to
the roller skating rink at the mall
new mall and uh they used to have
breakouts
what's up big time
you know i would yo you want to go in
the parking lot and do a little
battle oh you do you think i you think i
was scared of doing a little battle bill
so when did you when you saw bring it on
do you look were you like
[ __ ] why didn't why didn't i make write
that movie i lived that movie
i remember going and watching electric
boogaloo
uh you know that that uh that was an 80s
like mid 8
right but we went as a group you know
the the break dancing group went
together we were like we should go see
this together so we can look at some
moves
oh yeah and the dude who was like the
manager of our group he was always like
writing things down now you should do
the backspin it
is um i'm i'm happy but also sad that
there isn't
at least one video of me in my
you know because we used to go to cape
cod in the summer sometimes
and they used to air spray those
t-shirts you know
and so i got everybody in the breakdance
group one of those airspray
t-shirts with their nicknames on it so i
had a sleeveless one that said j-rock
and yeah
none of this is embarrassing i don't
think it is this is all like
yeah in your career
as a dancer did you do more serving or
did you get
served more when you went out to the
parking lot at the new mall
outside of chess king i would say
let's stand for skinny leather ties i
i would say that i got served more than
i was serving i was not were you a
gracious loser
no i gotta go like shaken
no i was not a gracious loser and i was
a great [ __ ] talker
so people always thought i was going to
be better than i was
because i was j rock dude i was
did you go through an unfortunate phase
at all in high school like was did you
go through one that was just terrible
i don't think it's unfortunate that you
went through that phase i was i'm
i actually uh think that white kids that
were listening that way back in the 80s
and were saying no this is good
because when uh that electric boogaloo
came out we watched that movie and
laughed and thought it was ridiculous
like i didn't get anything and like i'm
just like oh this is
these people are crazy what are they
what are they spinning around their
heads for and just they were talking the
whole thing just sounded like
hilarious to me it was a comedy to me
not like this really like i i was so far
away from it
that it played as a comedy and then
years later you know you go back and
look back it's like no dude this was
like
yeah a a like a artistic revolution that
was going to go
global you know i know i was i was into
uh metal and the only reason why i
didn't grow long hair
was because my hair grew out like an
afro
so uh that's the only reason why
i i didn't have a mullet i tried to grow
a mullet
i wouldn't have and it would just keep
curling up like a [ __ ] shade you
can't pull down
it would just just keep going up
did you did you uh
now i in high school we call the mullet
a soccer cut
we didn't call it a mullet like in the
hockey door it was the schlong
hockey dude yeah yeah the hockey haircut
schlong
or something short in the front long in
the back and to see because i remember
going to those hockey
uh games in high school and watching it
and every dude
had just that curl coming out of the
bottom of his helmet that the
mullet was taken out did you play hockey
in high school
no i got a d in math fifth grade and
that was the end of my uh
my sports career where my
my parents felt that sports was taking
too much away from
my studies and little did they know that
it didn't matter because i still flunked
everything
so i played a lot of um i actually had a
lot of fun with sports growing up i
think because it wasn't organized i
definitely missed out
on a lot because of learning how to work
with other people and then also having
adults teaching you fundamentals
of all those great games that we have
and uh but you know i played pond hockey
and you know basketball football
baseball
you know we was new england that was the
four seasons
what sucked was i just remember playing
hoop outside
you know watching the celtics play in
the 76ers you'd want to go out
and play and it'd always be cold as [ __ ]
your fingers were cold like uh we never
thought but we we never thought to play
basketball me and my friends
in the summer time until we got older
because we
was like the red sox were on so we would
be playing baseball wiffle ball
uh what was that pitchers poison
remember that [ __ ] yeah
did you play games when you played
wiffle ball
did you play like uh because we played a
ton of wiffle ball growing up
but did you play with like people in the
field and [ __ ] like
actual games where you ran bases or did
you just have
yeah they had to be like a fence and
[ __ ]
and uh we had like trees with foul lines
and all that stuff
we got it we got into it then we would
go we got older you go to the
the little league parks you do like the
home run derbies yeah and you have guys
play against each other
it was really um
something socially that uh you know
there's a lot of things that you know
young kids i think oh that's really cool
that they have that
but then there's other things that i i
think
that um socially even adults now are
missing out like me and my wife last
night you know elaine
we're just we didn't say anything for 20
minutes we're just like looking at our
phones looking at
nothing looking nothing other than that
animaniacs clip which is the [ __ ]
most brilliant thing i ever saw
did you see i hadn't seen that you
remember that animaniac
song oh yeah where animation
totally zany and then they cut to this
woman who was at the capitol
she goes they push me and they tase me
and uh maybe
yes just watch the show and then there's
that little roll with the drums there it
goes yeah
and she went like like it was so [ __ ]
brilliant that somebody's
musical ear that when they saw that clip
i mean it was really like it was a
brilliant piece of comedy i mean aside
from whatever your political
belief is by the way what the [ __ ] is
antifa i just know whenever some [ __ ]
goes down
and somebody doesn't want to say that
that was our color tie everybody that
was antifa
yeah i'm gonna start using that with my
wife
antifa put an empty milk carton back in
the fridge i don't know that's their
move
uh i will you know dude the
thing that got me the like that the the
the
the pepper spray woman made me laugh but
what made me laugh the most
of some of the images and some of the
images obviously horrific but who
decides they're gonna lead a revolution
dressed like an ewok
like who's like hey who should we send
to be our representative
let's send jeff you have to be that
level of crazy
to do something like that i would think
now here's the thing i haven't watched
any of it and i sort of just
joked around about uh
the thing on my podcast and i was
surprised like there was not a bunch but
there was like a
half like a dozen people maybe really i
started my podcast i was like you know
it takes a lot
i joke around a lot on this podcast and
it takes a lot to upset me
but i i have to be honest what i saw
yesterday
it was disgusting and it broke my heart
those uniforms that the miami heat were
wearing against the boston celtics
flew in the face of everybody who fought
for this country i just felt triggered
i feel like the owner of the heat owes
me an apology
and i just did that [ __ ] right because
what the [ __ ]
i mean do you want me to like legit talk
about it it's like i'm a clown
i'm a comedian if you want to see people
talking about it well
you want to watch that [ __ ] go [ __ ]
put on cnn [ __ ] who i think
should have taken their responsibility
in
what they do which is divide america 24
7 365 that's
all they do yeah that's all they're
doing
and bill and and the people that i know
that watch those channels
are [ __ ] like
you know i gotta close the door here you
know my uh somebody uh you know
comes over my house watches cnn so i'll
walk by every once while and when i
watch that channel i i get like anxiety
when i go outside it's all right
the sky isn't falling no
but but but news is a business based in
fear
so you're not selling tickets to happy
but
nothing gets people motivated man like
somebody saying
hey somebody's coming to take something
you already have
that that to me fear is the motivator so
if i'm a news channel
and i want people to watch my channel
you i got to get them scared about
something yeah so as long as
they said that they were upset they were
psyched that was like an
easy news day great um i only saw a
little bit of it
i didn't watch any like i wasn't gonna
look at that and be like yup that's
that's
that's what a conservative is like it's
like no that's a [ __ ]
lunatic it's like they got lunatics on
the left i have like
i just watch old movies now i've been
watching a lot of uh
just just old [ __ ] movies i just do
that
uh my wheelhouse is uh
60s and 70s but a lot of 60s lately i
like
um i thought once upon a time in the
west somehow i missed that growing up
oh my god what a movie and i saw all the
other ones
sergio leone i think his name is did all
those um
and then i i've been watching some bunch
of french movies and [ __ ]
why are you a west were you ever a
western fan oh i love them growing up
i love me too i i i was magnificent
seven fistful of dollars the good bad
and the ugly
uh dollars more outlaw josie wales all
good
unforgiving i wasn't a big like um
did you watch unforgiven you know i
don't think i ever saw that one for some
reason i just never saw that i know it's
[ __ ] great because that's the closure
of that character
so i want to go back and watch all of
those ones again
and then uh watch the unforgiveness kind
of i feel like i have i
the amount of work that clinton
everybody put into that i owe it to that
character
to not just watch the conclusion and
then go back
so um yeah i've been doing a lot of that
in uh criterion channel like i
you know i've watched like a student
film
that had all uh black actors in it from
like
the late 60s in la and it was if the
sound was terrible
the editing was terrible but it's
fascinating
and i watched uh a chinese one
from 1967 in black and white one of the
scenes was a bunch of married guys
sitting around talking about their sex
lives
in 1967 and the [ __ ] they were talking
about was just it just sounded like guys
over here
this was 50 years ago all the way over
in china and i would rather
watch [ __ ] like that to see
similarities yeah rather than sit there
and watch 24-hour news networks where i
would have a [ __ ]
gun in my mouth or pointed it at
somebody else
you know because i am a sort of a
recovered conspiracy
theorists i still believe a lot of my
conspiracies
but i i just made peace with them that
you know
human beings you know we're we are
incredibly flawed
yeah like i'm having major major issues
with like a higher powered judging it's
like
you know at some point are you going to
take responsibility for your own work
here
like if you if you like somebody's like
born a sociopath they don't like make
the decision that i'm going to become
social
like i feel like the devil is like a
scapegoat
sort of to try to explain away all of
this [ __ ] well
you know god gave us freedom of choice
and blah blah blah blah and all of this
type of [ __ ] and i just um
bill i i would understand if
individually
you paid for your actions but just the
amount of innocent
great people that end up crossing paths
with some broken toy of a human being
and what ends up happening to them and
they did nothing [ __ ] wrong
is where i have let's that's that's the
the grand expanse that i've never been
able to come back
to a religion that made sense to me
because since i had kids i'm like okay
this is like
making me feel there has to be there's
something going on here
that religion doesn't have the ability
to explain in a way at least
that i understand or maybe i'm too
stupid to understand it who knows
did you grow up in a religious house
yes like not like not like
you know mother mary on the wall but
like there was a time
i had a cal ripken junior streak of like
i went to i didn't miss mass for about
17 years even
into my 20s dude like i would go out and
get
[ __ ] hammered and dragged my hungover
ass to like 7
30 mass because he didn't want the later
ones and he started singing and [ __ ] it
took the [ __ ] ever
i will tell you i as a jew obviously i
never went to mass
and um i found um
first of all i found it more enjoyable
than going to temple just because i
could understand all the words
i remember growing up thinking how do
you know what the [ __ ] they're saying
like oh you're saying you enjoyed going
to mass more than temple or you enjoyed
at first i enjoyed going to mass because
i because i
more than temple because i understood
the words like i i until they got the
power they said the jews killed christ
you're like
maybe maybe peppa wasn't not bad
yeah that's when i was like oh god it
got it got it wrong
wrong dojo but i will tell you man
i think in a oddly similar way
conspiracy theory and please folks i i
don't
think there's anything bad with the
religion i the one thing i think that is
very positive
i do think there's some bad i think the
thing that is positive is that it gives
people
a place to gather with a sense of
community and i always think that's good
now
when that community starts to go down a
squirrely path and starts to say
you know preach violence or any [ __ ]
like that that's terrible but i like
that it gives people hope and a sense of
faith right i think that's a good thing
however the one thing that i think that
religion and conspiracy theories have
in common is the boogeyman like if
you're just allowed to blame something
that you can't see
or that is bigger than you to make you
feel better
or not blame or to you know what i mean
to invoke
and i feel like religion is a lot of
it's like you know you ever click on
something going you're like
you know there's a food out there
that'll actually give you a flat stomach
in 12 minutes and over the next half
hour i'm going to tell you what this is
and after a while you're like just
[ __ ] say what it is what is it and
then there's never the answer
yeah i always end up tapping out before
i get like why is this taking a half
hour
for you to say bananas
or [ __ ] uh pickled something or other
like anyway i feel like religion is like
that where it's like
it's like you can't in here god's gonna
love you we're gonna explain the
universe and
over the next blah blah blah blah you
know it's just they never
get to the whole yeah i don't know what
it's just like
you know that's how you gotta have faith
and you gotta blah blah it's like
faith is listen you know what happens
i used to say is my act you don't know
what happens nobody knows what happens
till they die until they die
right i remember seeing a thing right
now uh somebody was talking about this
where their grandmother used to say when
somebody died saying
they know the secret they know the
secret
because they just died so they know what
happens and that's what i think about
all my friends that have died i've lost
so many [ __ ] friends man it's
terrible
but i i i always think that like they
all know
yeah we all know what happens do you
it's funny you know
you you've actually lost a bunch of
comedy friends too
like a bunch i was actually mostly
comedy friends fortunately
you know unfortunately i mean i've lost
um geez i don't know how many classmates
from
high school and stuff but uh you know i
keep a list i have all the names written
down i always look back and look so i'll
remember
them and stuff because you know each one
of those people you know we had good
times we had laughs and stuff like that
and uh i'll tell you like i i forgot i
forgot the numbers it's something crazy
it's like up to like 50 or 60 people at
this point and
uh or 40 50 something like that
and that is that's a ton say there's 45
44 of them are men yeah
it's just like i mean
yeah it's like it's uh
yeah i was actually doing i don't know
why that is a and by the way
actually probably because i don't really
have any female friends
by the way a lot of people in the chat
are loving you on mandaloria man just so
you know um
oh yeah i gotta thank uh john favreau
rick family
wrote directed he he did both the
episodes that i didn't uh
i'm dying to do you know something else
with either one of those guys if i don't
know if they'll ever bring my character
back or whatever but
um that was john favreau's idea and the
guys in the writers room when they wrote
that character
mayfeld and they were like they kind of
they had me in mind it's not like i
auditioned and beat out a bunch
of people i was lucky enough that they
liked my comedy so
but you auditioned for breaking bad
right yes i did and i
i think i read for um because they just
gave me sides
from episodes they already shot
so i think i read some of badger's sides
you're like who's jesse's friends
yeah one of my badgers one of my
favorite characters in any show
that dude was absolutely bananas but i
think you probably read
my friend who grew up in town next to me
in massachusetts in northampton was a
woman named sherry thomas and i think
sherry cast
thomas bialy probably cast breaking bad
and she
loves using comics like she um
she had a bunch of comics number one
because i was always wondering
because there was a lot of comics on
that show at one point we were doing a
scene
and and it was me lavelle crawford
and uh bob odenkirk
so you know he played saul i played uh
kuby and um huell
and what was cool was a quick little
scene before mr white came in so i was
already sitting there going like holy
[ __ ] i can't believe
i'm in saul goodman's office then it was
my favorite show
and it was like being you know sitting
in the diner on seinfeld or being at
arnold's on happy days whatever [ __ ]
you were into right and uh the top of
the scene
you know happens it's just a little back
and forth i think we were talking about
that guy
ted benneke um
and uh i remember right before we did
the scene ago you know what's [ __ ]
cool this is the best drama on
television right now
and for like these eight seconds at the
top of this scene
there's nothing but stand-up comedians
driving the ship
yeah then of course brian cranston came
in and was
like all right that's an actor
but you know what sherry told me once i
had her i interviewed her once
um and she by the way she got me my sag
card i was on uh home improvement
i had a line uh i remember man
when i got that gig um
i was single raising the three kids and
we were all living in one room
and my biggest perk was that wardrobe
said i could take the shoes home with me
and i was like get the [ __ ] i can't eat
these shoes and they're like yeah i was
like come on
but um i remember thinking
that very first set i was on
how different it was from stand up like
i i went in thinking oh i do stand up
this is going to be easy
i perform in front of people and
i remember like think like oh saying
other people's words
for me anyways is so much harder
it's so much more difficult and
the the responsibility or not
responsibility or
but what i'm trying to get out of the
people who are watching is so
different than what i'm trying to get
out of the people watching my stand-up
that i i remember like i'm just
i have to change my approach altogether
because
for me comedy isn't about listening and
acting is
all about that listening to what is
happening around you you know
yeah i know it's completely universal
yeah and and stand up if anybody says
anything you tell them to shut the [ __ ]
up and then you're going to happen
so then when you're doing like that
comedy thing you now
you it's like okay i did comedy but i
wasn't
in a comedy team so you have to learn
how okay so it's
in this part i'm doing the setup so i
need to lob this over the net so you can
crush it
um or the other way around like you know
how to do the punchline so i used to
watch
you know jeffrey tambor was a guy that i
got a lot out of with
when he was on larry sanders show um i
got a lot out of watching him where
it's like this guy is not trying to be
funny at all
he's just playing the scene and he
believes
he believes everything that he's saying
like jeffrey tambor in in
the larry sanders show was such a high
water mark for me as far as like
um just how complex that character was
just to be that level of success but not
quite larry yeah dealing with that and
and
and to be like
i don't know he just had like this thing
where it was like he had the ego of a
guy on a show
and also that just that grand canyon of
insecurity and the way he did it was
just so believable
and funny and and just watching him
basically fighting for respect
like just just think of the mind [ __ ] of
that that you're on a tv
show the biggest talk show right of of
that time and you're famous and you're
on it
but people still don't respect you like
what that would do to you to be like
what the [ __ ] do i have to do like i've
seen that with like comics
where you know a lot of us had the
classic uh
you know childhood recipe that makes you
need to be a comedian
right right and then and your thing is
i'm gonna get on stage i'm gonna make
people laugh
people gonna think of funny and the
world's gonna stop
[ __ ] with me and then you reach the
apex of your career and there's this
backlash like some of those comics that
have just gotten backlash yeah and it's
just like
oh wait i was trying to leave high
school behind
and now i have a national high school
of people on the internet like now i
feel like i'm walking into a cafeteria
there's no place for me to sit
and now it's the entire country like
just this i don't know how that happens
but there's like a few comics that i've
seen
go through that where it just became
open season on them
yeah especially now man and a few
brought it on themselves
running their yaps too much i should
talk but um other
other people it was just that they were
just sort of did a nicer act
weren't really edgy but that wasn't who
they were and they found their audience
and they were living their dream and
these [ __ ] on the internet
because it wasn't pushing any buttons
rather than just
moving on yeah they were like they
literally like oh you're the person i'm
going to take my childhood out on
let's all gang up on this person i've
seen it happen to actors and just
well it's easy dude it's a mob mentality
but you know what's funny is you
basically just described
um my comedy journey
in that i remember watching
guys like you and and uh
patrice and uh
guys who had a bit of an edge and a bit
of an anger to them right
and i always remember thinking i uh i
wanna
that's that's how i wanna deliver my
material
and then it took me a bunch of years to
realize
i'm not an angry dude so though
you're not i'm obvious to that patrice
wasn't angry either
anybody who's watching patrice was not
angry he
patrice to me if if he is not on a mount
rush you're mount rushmore of stand up
you're not watching stand up
i watched uh a bunch of that's another
thing with my higher power
it's like why take that guy what that
guy could have
done right now right now oh come on like
since he's gone like a whole me too
thing right
up to this trump [ __ ]
i mean you know his um he did 20 minutes
one time about martha stewart going to
jail it was one of the funniest [ __ ]
things
i ever saw it caroline's in front of
like 30 people
was he funny um off the cuff funny
like just getting on stage and just
talking no it was a [ __ ] show dude
it was just a show and and he just took
breaks doing stand-up the show was him
off stage
it was all the same it just bled in it
just didn't stop
i remember hearing like prince would
play like [ __ ] you know
he would play uh you know running dates
at the forum and then last night he'd go
to like the house of blues and just jam
yeah just did it just that's just what
he was he was a musician
he didn't give a [ __ ] how many people
were there what style of music and he
would just
do it because he loved it to get better
to just
[ __ ] with people that hey was that
prince up there with that bluegrass band
or some [ __ ] whatever you know
but like i think um patrice was
the same way where he was he was uh
i've said this on a million interviews
like i remember one point
watching him [ __ ] with like the 15th
millionth person out on the street and
it was so funny and then this this
sadness came over me
because i was just like you know someday
he's going to be
famous and he's not just going to be
this guy that
like nobody knew that he was there's a
comedian he's one of the best comics out
there
they just didn't know who he was and
there was this that great
period that i got to see and i was just
going to be there's going to be a day
where you know that fame thing he
they're people going to expect it like
oh i'll see he's doing the thing that's
what he does on the blah blah
so i was just like really sitting there
i remember in that moment just going
like i need to enjoy this
because this guy is going to be so
[ __ ]
huge um
i mean that guy what do you think it was
funny and profound that i saw that he
made
a lot of
a lot of people uh
that were way beyond him
just would become either totally
enamored by him or like really
intimidated
and like try to you know
try to bully their way into it so they
realized that he was this unstoppable
force
um was it because he was so
um free on stage
like it because he didn't have one he
was you know he
he was so conversational which was which
to me is the goal right you to me the
goal is
is to just be conversational and and for
me to talk and then
for the audience is part of the
conversation to be the laughter right
if that's the style you want to do yeah
because yeah
i love joke writers too yeah okay you
you know i
i i took a job bill um
writing for foxworthy on are you smarter
than fifth grader because
i know how to tell a story but i just my
joke writing skills were always really
not as sharp you know and i remember
taking that
job to go okay i'm gonna have to write
at least one joke about every question
so um and they're gonna have to be in
foxworthy's voice
and so there's gonna be a great exercise
for me and i remember part of my
contract
because the pay was nothing was in the
contract was that foxworthy had to talk
to me about comedy every lunchtime
that was a deal if i had comedy
questions he had to sit and talk to me
and we had the same manager at the time
and but i remember taking the job
and uh and writing jokes and at the end
of it thinking
this is a completely different skill
skill set that like that larry the cable
guy kind of cadence you know what i mean
is just something that i just don't have
that's that happens to me with like rose
jokes
you've said that when you didn't i have
to sit down and write a rose joke
i have like a whole ritual i have to do
what is it i sit out on my back porch i
smoke a cigar
back in the day i'd have a little booze
but i just start
talking to myself and i start talking
[ __ ] because that's how
i do jokes is i just look and i start
talking so to i was finding that sitting
down
going like okay david ortiz
is here i just didn't do that i just
pictured i was picturing myself
sitting across from him breaking his
balls yeah so that's how i had to do it
so it was very conversational
and i just sort of had my recorder on
and then
in these little things i was doing then
came
like stuff and then came like an order
and then i would i would run them by uh
i i really like i've done a
few things i've written jokes for uh
you know i recently got to do it for an
athlete i'm not going to say the names
or anything like that i was so weird
like that's some locker room [ __ ] i keep
it in there but i i i've done that
and um it ends up becoming this fun hang
on because what i do is if if i get the
gig
i then call up two of my buddies who are
also huge sports fans
and it's just like i'll you know i'll
give you guys some some of this money
they've given me
and let's just all hang out and make
write [ __ ] jokes about like you know
the minnesota vikings or the uh whatever
you're supposed to be making fun of and
it just becomes this
we feed off of each other and we're just
laughing our balls off and a lot of the
[ __ ] we're pitching we know
they're not going to use but but then
what happens is all of a sudden you're
just in that mindset it's the weirdest
thing and for like two days
after the gig i can't shut it off all of
a sudden like this joke
hey let me tell my wife okay you know
all of a sudden i'm in that mindset i'm
like
wow so that
that weekend in austin was a ton of fun
man you know that was a good hang
we got to do uh we we um
bill and i and a couple other people
adam ray sarah tiana
lenny clarke [ __ ] legoland
yellow pants and by the way lenny's
ripped
jeffy lenny looked jacked dude that guy
that guy the most amazing things he ever
did was become fat
that guy is so [ __ ]
like his idol is like third gear for
anybody else
he's the funniest he's the only guy i've
ever seen smoke a cigar not look relaxed
like this guy this guy had to be
comedian this guy just
this no this guy if you stuck this dude
in the cubicle he'd be climbing the
[ __ ] walls
he told me once he referred to a certain
part of his comedy career as the
sweatpant years
because he said he was so big he could
just wear sweatpants
that [ __ ] guy i remember a couple
times
in the early 90s you were just like uh
he's not
he's not seeing the end of this decade
and then all of a sudden
he he got off of uh you know that
that wheel and ever since then now i'm
sitting the [ __ ] guy
can do 20 pull-ups i know
jack but billy you know i the same thing
for me
you know i uh joey diaz and i started
together you know in seattle
me and joe and brody and uh
joe's lived in my house a bunch and we
go back a long time
and i remember talking with him openly
about telling him there's no way you
reach 50 years old dude
there's no way you know i think he was
at one let me tell you something
[ __ ]
but at his heaviest he was over 400
pounds bill
oh yeah oh yeah
he was a big [ __ ] dude he was do you
know
so just like lenny he has no middle
ground he went from not smoking
cigarettes
ever a day in his life to smoking a pack
and a half a day the first day he smoked
cigarettes he smoked a pack
and a half oh wow so that's
you know that that's who he is but i
remember
that's but that's also why his comedy is
so great
because if he's going to do a subject
you know he's smoking the whole pack you
know what i mean he's not going to
sit there and just be like well this is
kind of interesting no he's not leaving
anything on the table at all yeah
do you know i remember when we started
with him and i don't know if you know
anybody that you started with that did
this
brody and him were the same in that when
they were doing their actual jokes
they were bombing and they didn't kill
until they got so mad that they were
bombing that they just started to become
themselves
and as soon as they started like as soon
as brody was brody was bombing one night
and he bombed in a unique way that like
nobody bombed like him
and he went into this thing about he was
like
you know you guys are laughing but he
said i'm a little anxious tonight
he was like do you know how hard it is
for a single man
to shave his own back he said i have
trouble spots and he turned around and
he lifted up his
shirt and he had like patches of hair on
his back where you could see
he
and i was like oh this dude's [ __ ]
crazy
but when he did [ __ ] like that it blew
it up
but when he wrote jokes he was like a
completely both of them
were completely their jokes made them
seem like completely different people
than who they actually were
when joey went off listen here
[ __ ] that's that's some funny
[ __ ]
people went crazy but like
yeah brody's one of those guys you know
where
i don't know how many thousands of times
i saw him do stand up but i can't
remember
anything other than laughing my ass off
and looking
at another comedian going like
just being like can you believe this
[ __ ] like
like he really was just doing his
own uh
his own thing i think the thing about
that this it's this weird thing where
they're not traditional comedians right
but they're [ __ ] hilarious so they
almost have to go up
and go all right here's stand-up comedy
yeah and then they try that there was a
guy uh
nicostas was like that out of boston
he had these jokes and but you know they
would do okay or whatever but when he
got
frustrated or somebody [ __ ] heckled
him and he
snapped one of my favorite things ever
when i was coming the boston scene was
when i was a buddy of mine would call me
up
and be like dude nick [ __ ] snap
tonight
at dick dougherty's oh my god what
happened what happened
it was just always it was always got a
goddamn flying here it's always um
you know what's funny people there's
nothing to like i have a story of that
guy
snapping but i don't even know how to
make it funny it was the way he did it
he was on stage
and he had finally got in his own room
okay and then they started to roam and
they and they wanted to make him the
host
he was booking a room yeah so they had
him booked the room but it was like one
of those guys
i think was dick dougherty he had like
all these satellite rooms so they had
this downtown
um uh what a kenmore square i think was
comedy campus they would take comedy
campus thinking that this would get all
these college kids in there so
you show up the first night and it was
like [ __ ] i don't know it's like 12
people
in the crowd going to spread out and he
goes up to warm him up and he doesn't
get him he just sort of eats it
then he brings up the first comic the
first comic goes up there and just
you know gets them going it's going good
blah blah blah
thanks a lot after nick so then nick
comes back up on stage
immediately it's not going well again
they're just not getting them right
so this goes on the whole [ __ ] show
so
uh i think fitzsimmons was
had driven up from new york and he was
driving back that night so
he said to him he goes look he goes nick
we got plenty of show man if it's not
happening for you
just start bringing up the axe and that
[ __ ] piss nick off because nick was
[ __ ] hilarious it just wasn't
happening for
so he went up on stage again and he
starts doing his act and it's not
working and i can see in his
forehead he's gonna [ __ ] snap
he does another joke it just [ __ ]
lays there
and just fine goes he says you know what
what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] kind of
jokes do you [ __ ] people want
this guy goes how about some funny jokes
he goes yeah [ __ ]
funny how funny how huh
like things going in and out of your ass
and the way he said it
he said it with such vile
and hatred in his voice
you actually pictured this guy's [ __ ]
puckering up as he was shoving [ __ ]
and the whole crowd horrified
horrified and me and fitzsimmons were in
the back
just [ __ ] just just dying
dying and i and i remember
dude that guy was a [ __ ] lunatic i
remember one time
we were doing this gig it was down near
northeastern
and uh it was this downstairs bar that
had you know those shitty like
push-up ceilings like when your buddy
had finished his basement they had like
that
and for whatever [ __ ] reason they had
a lifeguard
chair down there that was like made all
out of wood
i don't know it was probably for some
other stupid event and everybody was
going up on stage
making fun of the giant you know
lifeguard chair they bring nick up and
he had the presence of mind to climb up
it and sit in it like you like a
sit-down comic so now
he was gonna be like nine feet in the
[ __ ] air so he's climbing up he used
to wear a sport coat too
with these these [ __ ] uh uh son of
sam shoes and no socks
and he's climbing up this [ __ ] thing
like an ape and he's tall as [ __ ] so
when he gets up to the top of it
his head disappears into the ceiling
and then comes back down again standing
up there
and then he crosses his legs like he's
sitting at some
in somebody's backyard on a lawn chair
[ __ ] murdered it didn't matter what
he said like the whole crowd he didn't
even say hello he just started climbing
this thing
and people just were [ __ ] with holding
the mic and he's trying to get up there
in this dumb ass suit
um so he like that guy like
when crowds got him i mean i don't think
there was anybody funnier like he was
like one of those
comics comic guys and then like um brody
was like that where
yeah it's like i remember when he passed
and there was so many
that's so many but i got no dude i watch
this guy's clip this guy isn't funny
it's like dude
because this isn't it this isn't what he
did like they never really captured what
he did uh although uh the zack alfinaka
show they did on comedy central was the
closest thing
yep like those are guys you just you
it's like dude you can't just see this
guy once
you can't watch him on tv this is a guy
you have to go
you have to go to the club yeah
and you have to get to where his brain
is at and then once
once that you guys are on the same
frequency it's like you push through the
matrix and this guy's going to make you
laugh like a [ __ ] comedian
a hundred percent you have to
you had to see brody live there was no
doubt about it 100 you had to see him
live and i
so for me with brody what was you know
how you said he's not a traditional
comic because he actually had you
laughing at things that if you
looked at if say he wrote his punch
lines down on a piece of paper
you might not be able to pick out the
punchline like the fact that he got a
laugh off of his gpa
right he would tell you what classes he
took at arizona state
and what his gp what his gpa was and he
had people laughing
that to me was like he was he was so
different which is why i think it was
inverted
yes with everybody else there was there
act the crowd laps you walk over to get
a drink of water
then you're back in your aft he's
getting a drink of water was his jokes
he did it opposite exactly
watched a ton of comedy i don't think it
made sense what
how his brain was it was like he was
literally up as down black as white
right his left
the whole thing was on its head and i i
think that that's why
uh i know he's just he was just
so [ __ ] billy i remember
to this day i still can't even explain
why what he was doing was funny
what he was saying i always tell the
story the one thing i really vividly
remember was one night he went up there
and described his dream two-bedroom
apartment
and all he was saying was details
yeah but that's funny coming out of this
boat that's funny
stepping down into
apple cider vinegar like why does that
matter
girl yeah doing all stuff like that uh
bill you know one time on the table
might be real
might not be negative energy arms
crossed negative energy arms crossed
we i saw i just i can't even
in seattle yet the old comedy
underground did you ever play the old
comedy underground
i played that one that that guy he used
to give you a shoebox full of cash at
the [ __ ] end of it that guy
terry yeah yeah that was giggles that
was gay
that guy was a character into the yeah
he literally gave you a door deal
so it's like all fives and ones and 20s
and 10s all
jammed together it's just like dude what
the [ __ ] is this
i'm not going to the airport looking
like some drug dealer yeah and he used
to say count it up i think it's all
there i'm like
what i don't but one time in seattle
pioneer square is where comedy
underground was next to the comedy
underground
was just a place where there was a lot
of homeless people and there was a dude
who was dressed like a clown um
and like basically it looked like
15 years ago he had performed at a party
as a clown
and just never took the costume off and
lived
outside from that time do you know what
i mean like the flower just happened
yeah yeah something about clown
makeup that you can never quite wipe off
well no it was smearing
the joker they go crazy there's
something about that [ __ ]
it's it was smeared his he would push
his flower and it just dribbled
it was sad right but brody brings him on
stage one night at the comedy
underground the open mic
um because he was always a very
experimental dude and for me
one of the things that that is one of
the things that i always admired about
him especially early on
to be such a young comic and be so
experimental
i didn't have that kind of confidence do
you know what i mean to really go up and
try something that you pretty much knew
was going to eat dicks
was not something i had the capability
to do
but he always did and he brought this
clown on stage and i forget what his
name is he's like joe
george whatever he goes everybody this
george
you know i'm sure you've seen him down
out here in pioneer square but george
you know i've talked to him the last
couple weeks and he's always want to be
a comic
so i'm going to give him my time for the
open mic and go ahead george
and so there's you know about 30 or 40
people down there and
george tells a couple of jokes and uh
they're not funny believe it or not and
um
but you know the crowd thinks this is
part of the gig they don't think it's
actually some homeless dude
off the street and george you can see
him
he's not holding it together quite as
well he's
no laughter is really starting to get to
him so brody can sense that
and he walks up and he puts his arm
around him and he goes come on everybody
this is george's dream let's give george
a little energy and george looks at
brody he goes
touch me again and i'll murder every
[ __ ] person in this room and i was
like oh boy
you might have brother and how did brody
handle it
he was like george everybody come on one
more time for george and he grabbed the
mic and they gave him the light
it was really you know he was um
you could put him in any situation
i remember dude one of the gigs i was
most excited to get
that i bombed at um i was supposed to
couple years ago maybe five six years
ago i was gonna perform for the dodgers
and i'm a big sports fan like you and
that kind of [ __ ]
geeks me out a little bit you know if
you're going to ask me those are
those are hard gig is it just the
dodgers yes
yeah i do not know how i've done one of
those gigs that those can be
you got to get them quick because they
all know each other i found what you do
is you make fun of somebody on the team
and then they all love it but don't jump
right into your material which
i did it went so poorly tommy
sort of got on stage after me and made
fun of me
he was like alright buddy i'm just going
to do 10 minutes now it seemed like an
hour that last guy how long was he up
here
i mean he was everything that didn't
work for him he was like at least it's
been funnier than that last guy right
i mean he was by the way rest in peace
time in the sword
oh did he pass i thought he recovered
i thought he passed i thought i read
that this morning oh did he pass this
oh my god he almost made 90 though right
93 i think he would 93
93 you know that guy that guy was
literally
the face of baseball for me hey
you look at that guy if he had street
clothes on you like
you're you managed a baseball team like
he just him
don zimmer there was just some guys uh
like joe morgan a bunch of some big guys
really passed away was just like
listen i love listening to joe morgan
like his love of the game
yeah i agree with those guys that uh
which i always love when
an athlete gets in the broadcaster booth
if they're good
you know what i mean if they're good you
you hear they're still their passion
for their game and for the game and and
getting excited
for younger players i love jerry remy
i think he's the best remdog yeah i
think he's
really good like i really uh for
especially for the people who watch
the red sox i think he is the absolute
perfect color commentator like i i think
he's so good
and he was a red sock and he was a red
sock on some of those teams that you and
i
watched you know the first team i
watched i still remember it was carton
fist
george got jerry remy rick burleson
butch hopson
fred jim rice fred lynn and dwight evans
yep
yep that was and was it rich it was
carlton fist not rich gedman not yet
profits no gedman wasn't around until no
there was also gary allen
oh yeah some of the games muggsy i think
was his nickname
who was dh for that team what year you
talking about 78
was jazz on the team yeah yes might have
been first
george scott might have been i bet you
rice scott and yaz kind of did left
field first base
dh a little bit well i know stremski was
in left field when bucky then hit that
home run
he was the one who looked up and just oh
yeah are you
a are you a when you think of boston you
think boston has a red sox town
a patriots town a celtics town bruins
like
when you think of boston sports for me i
think of the red sox
it's like any other sports town whatever
team is hot
it's you're gonna see that that's the
gear everybody's wearing
yeah um hockey's obviously huge
but basketball's huge like what i you
know what i do love i love
that the sound of the old boston garden
came over with the celtics it didn't
with the bruins
yeah i think with the bruins it's just
the way that that thing is set up
and how big the ice is and how far away
the fans are it doesn't but like with
basketball how you're right up there on
the baseline
and you know guys dive and they go into
the freaking crowd it's like wrestling
basketball
there's like no barrier there's um
the the thing that i love is uh a sports
intelligence
by a crowd and celtic fan like all the
boston teams have it
um you know yankee stadium old yankee
stadium what i miss is that
sound in the playoffs as much as i hated
you know the yankees or whatever
like the fans knew yankee fans knew the
game
so well you know they're the ones who
started that clapping on
with two strikes yeah like just like
doing were you ever ready i remember
watching a celtics game
and the officiating sucked and the crowd
started chanting cba
yeah the fact that everybody knew about
the cba like you were
i remember what's history bob costas
loved it
he's like oh and the crowd is training
see me he's like
that is high sports intelligence you
know so
um i always felt like uh
and it's what i gotta be honest with you
what i crave living in las every once in
a while i'll meet an old school
like the last lakers came up to i went
to an old i they had a little cigar bar
i didn't even know that in the [ __ ]
staples center so i went down there
whatever
like an idiot and um i smoked one
and uh there was a guy there and i got
to sit there as a celtics fan he knew i
was a celtics fan
but he loved the game i loved the game
and i got to talk we
sat there and talked about the showtime
lakers versus the boston celtics
and i was you know we just talked the
game and i got to ask him what was it
like going to the forum and
yeah he goes oh there was nothing like
it you know this place it's not the same
and it really isn't like these new ones
are just so
enormous but where the old school ones
it was just like
it was just a court in seats well you
got to remember
seats that's all it was with the new
ones so much
i think and i could be wrong because i'm
wrong a lot about a lot of [ __ ] but i
think so many of the seats are bought by
corporations
that it's not the real fans especially
right up and close to the court or close
the field if you look at new yankee
stadium
and sometimes you're like there's nobody
it isn't
it isn't you can you can still hear
those hardcore yankee fans but it's just
like
do you remember when they go to the game
they just [ __ ] eat because i got
those
all those uh somebody hooked me up on
time with those behind the home plate
dude that seems that food you can get at
the new yankee stadium
was crazy and it was a hot summer day so
i felt but i felt guilty was like i
gotta [ __ ] go out there i gotta you
know
fill in some seats but there's so much
good food back there
i i took my dad um to that new yankee
stadium
um and we got seats right behind at the
time
uh i was with an agency and was doing
well enough that they gave a [ __ ] about
me so they gave me some good tickets you
know
and so i was right there on like we put
our beers on the yankee dugout
my dad is wearing a red socket right
he's wearing a [ __ ] red sox hat and
we're walking in and i go dad
you know somebody gave me these tickets
like i don't want to be disrespectful
this is like the team and he was like
i'm 75 years old
i don't really care and i was like yeah
that's a good attitude
he was like what are they going to do
somebody going to fight me because i'm
wearing a red sox adam like no you're
you're probably right about that i think
we'd probably be pretty good
i wouldn't do that either like i
wouldn't uh if i went to a yankee game
somebody hooked me up with those tickets
like i mean i root against the yankees
but quietly i'm not going to i'm not
going to be in the [ __ ] and ruin your
[ __ ]
time there you know because that's
happened to me took my mother to a
bruins game bruins flyers i should have
known better three flyer fans behind me
four or five man
didn't shut up the whole game person
just [ __ ] [ __ ] and then we lost
it
i was so pissed when i left so i was
just like do you
the way philly fans do it it really is
an art form
oh they're good just take it being a
[ __ ] to like you know
someone like me like wow i i never
thought to do that that's a good one
they're relentless is what they are
there's no
there's no quit in that philly fan if
they're going to get on you
you know what it is it's all they have
it's all they have they're starving for
championships
it's like being [ __ ] is what they
like the fan base has more of an
identity than most of their teams most
years
unfortunately because i was a big
phillies fan i loved that 1980 team
and as much as i hated the sixers
because i was a celtics fan
like my favorite team of the 80s
was the 82 and 83 76ers oh my god i love
that team
was that the woman alone moses malone on
the team
he was on the second one daryl dawkins
was on the first one it was
mo cheeks andrew tony uh going back dr
j bill and uh andrew tony
killed the celtics like he was nobody's
nickname of the boston strangler was
just talking to something about that
danny ainge still tells i guess horror
stories about him
oh that dude killed the cylinder this is
how much he killed the celtics if
mitchell and ness ever put out an andrew
tony jersey
that i could that i'd fit i would buy it
and it's just that [ __ ] guy it was
you know who else
vinnie johnson was the next coming of
andrew tony as soon as the
if the pistons were played his name was
vinnie johnson right that tiny that
dude as soon as he stepped on the court
against the celtics i was like
here's 35 points right here that's like
there's some the thing about him was
lambear was such a douche i couldn't
take my eyes off of him
like lambie just had the star power like
he was like
like if bill lambert didn't play
basketball he could have been the
greatest heel
in wrestling ever ever
i don't think there was ever a guy that
got under my skin
the way that that guy i i [ __ ]
hated that you know have you heard
interviews with him that still
now he's still no i love him he's
hilarious because
my favorite thing was in that that
jordan documentary where they go
uh when they show the pistons walking
off
and like for some reason isaiah is
trying to plead his case
yeah you know and trying to be like you
know he's like sounds like he's always
running for mayor
and then they said to bill lambert he
goes do you regret not shaking hands
with the bulls and i get i didn't read
somebody told me he said this he goes
he's like
[ __ ] those guys when we wanted they said
we weren't real champions
and it's just like i love that he's like
a comedian that's not apologizing for
his first joke or for his act so
yeah um but i will say this
as much as i hated him as a player like
i never saw a big man
with that top of the key shot that he
had
top of the [ __ ] key like now as you
see that a lot with these
you know these nine foot white european
dudes yeah like it didn't make any sense
in the league back then a guy as tall as
him was that deadly
from that far away because all those
guys were down in the trees just banging
every night
and he had uh i also loved moses malone
moses malone had like guard moves like
he'd do like the double pump and come up
and underneath
yeah there was a buddy of mine who loved
him
from the boston area and he's just going
listen to that no matter what the [ __ ]
he gives
he goes they flip out about what we do
and then like moses comes in a double
pump
reverse layup and they're just like
moses for two
he's like give it up for the guy
but lamb in a uh in a cheesecake factory
in houston texas
way way back before obviously uh there's
a number of years before he passed
unfortunately
and um and uh i didn't want to bug him
but i want to say like dude i'm from
boston i'm a huge celtics fan i
[ __ ] loved you guys and i would put
the 83
sixers in a [ __ ] second up against
the 96 bulls in a [ __ ] second
you underneath against luke longley the
[ __ ] out of here you still got dr j
you got andrew [ __ ] tony so there's
there jordan and pippen
but moses moses moses is the big
equalizer i'm not saying that they would
win the series who knows
but this whole foregone conclusion that
the 96 bulls
would just mop the [ __ ] floor and i'm
not [ __ ] on the bulls because i
don't
they never said it it's it's sports
writers and stuff and
and i think a lot of times that you know
people look at like records and [ __ ]
and they just go well you had more
victory they'd really do like that that
sort of numbers thing like you know what
i've recently found out
about the 72 dolphins which i think
that's why the dolphins never won again
i think that because they're cursed
because of the the mot of the uh the bad
karma of the 72 team
just rooting for people to lose
and then toasting yeah champagne and all
of that [ __ ] right
so that year they went under undefeated
the winning percentage
they had one of the easiest nfl
schedules in history the winning
percentage was like 390 something
overall they played two of them two
teams over 500.
um well think about it did you know that
sucked that year
sucked dude
when you talking about the six was it
colts i don't know who's in the division
i should shut up but
uh in the 72 i don't remember who was in
there
but merger was only
a couple years old at that point so i
don't know what the divisions look like
um if only we had a computer we could
like look that up or something yeah but
then
i would have to really care hey i got to
pick my daughter up from school in like
five minutes so
uh all right okay so then do me a favor
man you know what i've been trying to do
on these friday podcasts
is one of the things that i uh obviously
small businesses are being
crushed under the weight of what the
[ __ ] is happening
so i've just been asking my guests if
they have any small business somebody
they grew up with or somebody
something from their hometown or
anything they'd want to promote to give
these guys a little bit of a shine
i'm really trying to uh to do that so i
do you have a small business you would
like to uh
promote i got a little restaurant that i
like go to
all right like fried chicken uh diners
chicken in glendale
dinosaurs uh california california
d-i-n-a-h
apostrophe yes um in this chicken huh
yeah is it a hot chicken no this is old
school just fried chicken everybody's
into the [ __ ] hot chicken now this is
just an
old school i don't mind i used to go to
that [ __ ] howland ray's used to be a
food truck right outside where i get my
head buzzed
back in the day and i said a little turf
on the field here um
and i would come out i would just i
could really just walk up to it now it's
in
chinatown i'm really happy for those
guys but i went down
i'm never getting another one of those
sandwiches the line is out the door
out the door down the block yeah around
yeah
you would think that they're [ __ ]
testing for covet in there
by the way wasn't that vaccine supposed
to come out this month
yeah you know i think i don't i don't
know if they've been uh if they had a
rollout plan uh that is working quite as
well as they had hoped this is how
cersei theory starts they they people
regular people cannot accept the fact
that we are in fact
this disorganized we are not and we
don't anticipate
we react because you're telling me
that you could just have a bunch of
people running to the capitol
that's what we learned yes yes
yeah that's what until they started
hijacking planes there was no
[ __ ] early 70s up until your 70s
there was no security no
right
did i lose you oh
all right there he goes well we lost
bill however
guys i mean
seriously could have talked to that dude
for hours
um howland reyes is if you live in
california
howland ray's is or if you live in l.a
howl and raise is so damn good
but he was talking about dinos and in
glendale i have been there as well
um a delicious sandwich we're back look
donut are you there hello yeah can you
hear me
i can hear you yeah yeah oh my damn
headphones aren't working
i was i was going to say that in the
early seven somebody just called me for
some reason i couldn't get rid of the
car
probably because i'm an idiot but like
they didn't have metal detectors you
could literally have a gun in your
briefcase to just get on the [ __ ]
plane
because no one had ever hijacked a
[ __ ] plane
in the united states and then all of a
sudden somebody did it and they were
like oh
metal detectors you know my favorite
part
and i know you flew on these planes why
isn't this
scare you i can hear you i can't hear
you you sound like you're making
i don't know what a turtle sounds like
but that's what you sound like i'm just
hearing like
cracking you can't hear me now i can
hear you
i think do you remember
i'm losing him again do you remember the
and i remember even at a young age
knowing how ridiculous it was
having a smoking section on a plane like
the smoke didn't make it up
but my dad because that seats right in
front of the smoking section
were super cheap so he used to always
buy those seats
but he was like no the smoking section
is back there so you guys will be good
i'm like
anything to save my dad man
we never let him now book a hotel
because if he can save
um i remember because i took him to the
masters one of my true
honestly for me the best part about this
job
is being able to do things for people
that i love that they wouldn't normally
be able to
do themselves do you know what i mean
take my dad to the masters
jacob got to be a bat boy for the
[ __ ] red sox
right dude right take him to a a a
a coke-filled orgy in the hollywood
hills that's a great idea
stuff you dream about
that's a that's a great idea i have to i
gotta go get my kid i
can't be that parent don't get us there
last so she doesn't think i love her
thank you so much man i really
appreciate you doing this uh it only
took us three years to make it happen
we figured it out dude thank you so much
for coming by dude
no worries all right brother thanks for
having me
you